[Music]
Colin Quinn was a great guy to this day
I still have a good relationship with
Colin but what's best about Colin Quinn
was he was one of the first people of
stature that embraced me and and made me
feel like a friend you know and because
he introduced you to Jerry Seinfeld and
Tracy Morgan and Chris Rock the banner
come here come in handy to make me just
got a nice little kid over here funny
little stupid kitty but it's funny a lot
of people get very territorial and they
say hey I don't want you getting friends
with my friends I want keep you away
nobody wants to give information nobody
wants to tell you why what you should do
or what you shouldn't do because people
feel like I should be here by myself
right I want people to know how to get
here I just want to be successful by
myself yes it's telling us I want to see
other people win I want to see people
achieve what they felt they couldn't
because you'll get a joyous oh you mean
you do that too there are certain people
you say hey can I give you some can I
tell ba let me tell you something man
just a piece of advice for you I want to
see people win